[Music]
right before we were going to start
filming we got that notice this morning
that roe v wade was officially
overturned by the supreme court wow
so for those of for those i'm speaking
for the people that stopped at a second
grade education
what does that mean and what are the
implications of that so pretty much i
think that i believe that um
abortion as in terms of it's like
federal protection has just been
overturned so now the uh
the i guess the laws abortion laws are
now being handed back to the states
which means that some states are
probably going to ban abortion you know
what i mean meaning that women in those
areas will have to um obviously carry on
with having children regardless of
circumstance yeah whether they be things
like rape or whatever
um or they uh will go back to a time
where you know people are illegally
seeking out how to like get rid of like
unwanted you know
circumstances like that i think mostly
democratic states will kind of like have
be in the same pocket they'll still be
able to make the decision to like
legalize abortion for women and stuff
like that but federally they're like i
don't want to deal with this you guys
deal
i guess for someone who doesn't
understand is that
bad is that a step forward for people
that want abortion to be legal is that a
step backwards if they put it back in
the hands of the state i think for women
it's definitely a step back where
they're not in control or the women in
the bible belt states that will make it
illegal to have an abortion they'll
probably suffer the most from this yeah
but i don't know it's um because there
are stats about how
whether it's legal
or not the people that want to do it
will do it and then they'll start doing
it in ways that are like unsafe bad like
the coat hanger method or some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] there's always going to be the
worst alternative before when the
abortion was uh not legal and like done
in clinics and stuff they were doing
them in [ __ ] like
like vets were doing it in garages and
[ __ ] you know so like how come no one
had the idea to make the states look
like a checkerboard where it's red and
blue
so if you need to like do certain things
like get the [ __ ] out of this one skip
over here and then skip back you know
like if you want to do this then you go
over here like you know what you got
king me and all of a sudden your chicken
go wherever the [ __ ] it wants it just
looks like canada versus mexico just
check this game there is i saw a map
like that of which states will probably
oh like
like make it illegal and which states
would like just keep it the way it is
now and then we'll still have the same
clinics and all that and it's mainly all
the uh west coast states so it's
california that's all legal abortion's
legal they'll keep this wise yeah hawaii
all the all the from washington all the
way down including nevada and then like
but when you go like to idaho classic
america
yeah more middle all the way down to
texas and then but some of them actually
that i thought were gonna be like super
red were act were in the middle oh yeah
so does it does it kind of align almost
perfectly with like liberal and
conservative yeah so then it's very
clear like which ones are my body my
choice and which ones what's crazy is
like growing up you know how like as you
evolve as a human being your thoughts
and opinions and positions on things
also change
i think since i was a kid and i heard
about abortion i've always had the same
like feelings about it since i was
uh i don't know maybe like 11 or 12
until now because i think the most
extreme circumstance i always think
about is
people that were raped
they have to keep it right even if it's
in sexual rape they have to keep it up
and i'm like why or
um
i also know it takes a whole community a
bunch of tax dollars to raise a kid so
if someone accidentally
who wasn't ready for it like you know uh
when i when i was in junior high there's
like two girls that are 13 that have
kids i'm pretty sure those kids are in
the right environment to be model
citizens
i'm like why would it
who are the people that are a hundred
percent against it and and why yeah
so that i could have the argument that i
hear from people that are against it are
they typically are like in the super
conservative christian states sounds
like morality issues it's for them it's
a it's an issue of like
everyone has a chance because they're
god's children and we should give them
that chance and not condemn them and and
they they feel that it's murder right so
if you grow up in that you're almost
doing god's work you're protecting god's
like because it's not
this other person's kid it's actually
like a living being that's a part of god
right
so it's like you have to protect them
too because you have to give them a
fighting chance even if they grew up in
a shitty circumstance even if they're a
result of ancestral rape it's like
that's yeah it's life is life right
god's plan life is life whatever so so
yeah but then
i think yeah you know the more uh uh
atheist point of view is more like
that's a pretty high probability where
you're actually like you know doing more
damage more damage by letting them live
and maybe they might live a a life of
suffering obviously we can't guarantee
that
we just don't know what the future is
also
impacting the the the mother who gives
birth you know what i mean yeah it's
like um
chances are well i'm not gonna [ __ ]
speak on statistics but like let's let's
just say like a young girl in that
situation wants to get an abortion but
can't anymore you know with the morality
of like making sure that god's children
her life goes on but then now this girls
maybe
dreams or ambitions or lifestyle or
anything like that are completely
different yeah it's changed and it's
obviously focused on motherhood and like
you know what i'm saying so it's it's a
very uh
very very difficult case-by-case concept
but yeah because it's you can't make a
blanket rule for something that is so
circumstantial because you can think
about it as like okay well some people
will say i'm against abortion in the
form of used as a form of contraception
like some people will will you know
maybe they'll have unprotected sex
throughout their youth and just like
party all the time and then they'll just
be like oh easy i'll just go get [ __ ]
you know abortion or whatever um but i
mean like but also you can argue the
other fact where
there are there is uh uh in the in the
book for economics where
they found out like
the reason for the crime rates
decline was when abortion became
legal and unwanted pregnancies from
young mothers from young single mothers
in lower income areas
didn't exist so then they didn't grow
and raise children that ended up joining
gangs and all this stuff that could
support either too right yeah and then
and so maybe these women were able to
further their education and get out of
the ghetto or whatever they needed to
and then change their situation and then
maybe they started a family or whatever
but the statistics are there for the i
guess that that of that like working out
in whether it was the 70s or 80s or
something like that so then like
it's really hard because like some of
these studies too it takes decades to
figure out what were the positive
effects that came from certain
situations and people are just arguing
a lot based on their imagination of like
what is this yeah and then and then also
people are arguing based off of
when is life
like is it at contraception because then
when are you killing is it
you know at how many weeks
and then that's why there's rules from
different countries different states of
like it has to be under like 20 weeks or
like whatever it may be or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then there's just all these
different gray areas it's yeah it's so
it's so different you know the morality
uh
thing is kind of interesting too because
like growing up in
the amethyst religion for example
it is a blanket opinion you're supposed
to have like it's unthinkable to even be
in a religion
and then have an opinion on abortion
it's like no obviously we all don't
believe that this is the right way yeah
it's like there's a right way to look at
it so you're not going to get varying
opinions from little ryan ever go but
what if and then you give a circumstance
or no well that's that's why i think
it's interesting is that in in that
religion we're all supposed to not even
think about it
but and we hella sda people have had
abortions yeah like they're just being
quieter about it yeah so then that's
where the double standard lies it's like
yeah you're gonna outwardly say like no
that's wrong don't do it but it's like
given the specific situation you might
wish you you can't judge other people in
those situations
we can't even imagine the idea of
incestual rape like when you grow up in
a sheltered christian community
that concept is so [ __ ] dark and
weird that
like if you look at statistically right
like most uh rape and molestation
happens from family members and all
these things and pregnancies unwanted um
not the majority of abortions come from
that but
that even concept is hard to fathom when
you grow up in a very
controlled christian community so then
maybe
you know the people that are making
these uh statements and voting a certain
way or whatever if i if we stuck to the
church
i'm pretty sure i wouldn't
even consider that fact i would i would
just be like yeah it's wrong yeah and i
vote against it we should save all life
get exposed to the creepy uncle or
whatever you don't think in those terms
so you don't know that that kind of
stuff exists you just think cute lives
matter and that's it also if you uh if
you were to accept and believe in the
ideology of like the governing body and
like democracy
i i can see and i'm not saying i fully
agree with this at all but i can see
like the court's opinion or overturning
this being like we're putting the power
back into the hands of the people and
their elected officials in their own
spaces you know what i'm saying because
it's like you know the age old like well
you put those leaders in place in your
state the state has the power to make
you elected them
or if you don't want to be in that state
because you don't follow those things
and like there are other states that
have different you know what i mean the
place you decided to live exactly i can
see how there's an idealism to the
concept of it but you obviously
nothing's that simple right yeah i think
there's two arguments to it right
because like there's one where it's like
you do have the freedom to move and even
poor people move like you could grab a
greyhound bus and just like uproot and
bounce people move all the time for like
jobs you know like poor people during
the great depression they'll be like oh
there's jobs [ __ ] they're building
the the the the hoover dam let's go
there you know my dad came here in a
container
your dad swam to hong kong literally
right yeah
but damn really yeah
[ __ ] a chinese takeout box i don't know
how you came here either one though
either one the other one or a pelican
case a wish a wish order
with a camera the pelican case is a
little bit of an upgrade i gotta admit
because
they got the phone
it looks great in here
like a human-sized pelican yeah what the
[ __ ] how'd your dad get here amazon
prime
that food came in a [ __ ] rum barrel
dude
[Laughter]
with one layer of fish at the top so
there's i mean so there's the the
freedom of like movement right yeah you
can go everyone can vote but like
realistically
pop like majority of people don't right
like that's why people like wherever
like if your parents are middle class or
poor or whatever or rich you stay that
class so like you probably are gonna
stay in your neighborhood if that's
where your family is or whatever so like
let's say you grew up in these bible
belt
areas you're lower income you don't even
have the option to like have a road trip
to go across state to do these things
now you gotta
you're kind of like maybe you gotta do
garage abortions or whatever and that's
where the federal laws protected
the uh i guess the people that that
didn't have the choice of movement
and just acknowledge the
little elephant in the room i apparently
there's only dudes here
i'm married nice i know i know a lot
about that
i think that is the important thing to
acknowledge though because like even
with all guys like all of us all of us
were birthed from mothers all of us have
like you know significant other spouses
i woke up this morning my sister-in-law
staying uh over at our spot and the
first thing that came out of her mouth
she's like i'm [ __ ] pissed right when
i thought i was a good morning i'm
[ __ ] pissed bro she's so ungrateful
that you housed her just complaining
your house
uh maybe ridiculous but you know what i
mean so it's just like even people in
proxy or we're obviously in the dance
community in the dance community like 99
people are more on the liberal side for
i think and even that dudes are more
feminine too some yes um but i think the
point is
uh you know what i mean it's like it
affects your community it affects the
people it affects us in different ways
and obviously we we
support and take the position of our
loved ones you know what i mean so i
think that this is a very very still
like um impactful type of situation even
for men because uh you have
relationships with women it's gonna pack
them you know did you guys ever have
that talk like um when you're just like
dating around or whatever just
from with uh your partners or like had
scares about like oh [ __ ] yeah this
might have to happen right
yeah we were like every single one of my
girlfriends we had like team abortion if
it happened yeah yeah we never like
had to do one but it was like if [ __ ]
ever like you know you always
brainstorming in emergencies or whatever
it's like every single one of my
girlfriends was i mean
the closest i got was like you know plan
b
like oh [ __ ] i busted like oh [ __ ] i
gotta go get this [ __ ] tomorrow um but
then i've had that conversation and i
think
early on like let's say from like high
school maybe even into college right um
i was actually okay to being a dad
because i didn't know what it took to be
a dad
so you know you're like extra confident
when you don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] right
and you're ready to be a father at 17
years old because you just think man i
sell drugs i make more than all my
friends and [ __ ] you know you [ __ ]
stupid i make 400 every time i go out
and sell
um
so i i was just like i could take care
of babies and [ __ ] right and then so
like i was like yeah [ __ ] like i got
little cousins
i thought
i was being the man by going man if you
have a cow [ __ ] i'll take care of it
and then i was like but it's your choice
because i was like ultimately whatever
you want to do you know it's your body
like whatever you want to do um if you
want to have the kid [ __ ] it i i decided
to bust whatever
uh but then at the older i got it
actually changed so i would say like in
my mid-20s and on i would just be like
oh please like we're not ready for this
because
i was thinking about can we afford this
commitment
and
do we have the time to do this and we
have dreams we want to pursue and i just
started thinking more about like the
future and i saw a kid as a burden
at in my in my mid to late 20s and then
i was like damn i'mma start wearing
condoms now all the time but i mean
those decisions are still stupid whether
you're 16 or 25 those decisions were
both still [ __ ] stupid
because there's no
prediction of the future there are
people that became extremely successful
when they had kids at an early age there
are people that you know i mean are
complete losers with no kids right so
like i don't know those are all just
like them it's all based on imagination
there's no guarantees circumstances for
sure maybe there's just this broader
ideology that uh you know all of us are
like first generation asian too like our
parents came here and there's this
concept of like the land of freedom and
stuff like that so um in a lot of other
countries we get that abortion is
illegal it's not a conversation you
can't do it blah blah and maybe uh
there's some sort of like hope that uh
in a land of the free things could be
free i know that it comes with it's a
double edged sword there's also issues
with that but maybe if there was like a
space people could have like america
kind of was that beacon for a lot of
reasons that's the whole point of it man
yeah and so you think if roe v wade was
overturned that was a 50 year ago
decision
every all of us none of us are 50 years
old so we've never known a life without
an option like that nor have our
significant stuff so it's it's way more
of like like you said like it takes a
long time to understand the
ramifications of something and we are
just in the generation where we're
finally for the first time women our age
are like i can't do this yeah i was born
into this you know that's true it feels
like we're taking a step back yeah i
wonder if it's just gonna keep repeating
itself probably yeah it could be oh
that's true because this is something
that people are probably gonna always
have
really strong opinions about yeah always
and generation also wonder you know it's
is religion
the real main reason why this happens or
is religion being used i think so
because if you think about
like western europe
i don't even think they have this
discussion in the way that we do
america is still a very christian state
like we like to talk about how you know
oh we shouldn't have separation i mean
we should separate church and state
right but we still pray yeah in our
politics like there would never be
a non-christian
president we're not ready for that yet
in god we trust the place you're
handling our
christians like yeah yeah because i mean
like in the uk it's way more atheist
like they have a church and stuff but
like no one's talking about god all the
time or like even you know
a lot of european countries
except for the eastern europeans so i
always wonder you know if it really is
truthfully the religion or if it's a
kind of a tool
yeah yeah yeah being kind of used
because we've seen both it's easy way to
keep like that sentiment in people's
brains you know and it's like being
reinforced through community and
religion at the same time it's also
cherry picking what people should be
guilty about 100
the weirdest thing is like in every uh
christian
uh religion it's like there's no one
without sin so
but then people are just like no being
gay is way worse yeah
but i also i also think america is
massive right and we have so much
diversity and culture and we're all
trying to make one rule for like imagine
having a country where you have
you can't have
it's difficult dude it's like how are
you gonna have like what do you call the
the muslim law the one sharia law sharia
law try to combine sharia law with like
atheist straight up western ideology and
then you have conservative christian and
you have like
all these things put together it's like
dude what i mean america doesn't have
shield law but it's that that difficult
how you gonna put it all together yeah
that's [ __ ] i don't know
diversity might not work
it's also a naturally occurring thing
that like i mean this has nothing to do
with like roe v wade but like it's a
naturally occurring thing that the
better things get like let's say
everything became totally serene the
next generation gonna pop up and
complain about everything yeah
definitely
there's no perfections there's no
perfection
[Music]
[Music]
you